Hey youtubers it's Charlie so big news
the Flash movie just lost it's director
just like what happened with Deadpool 2
very similar situation
So I'm going to explain what's going on he does
make it sound like a disaster but it's
not that bad
the headline you may have seen makes it
sound way worse than it actually is
when you read like the real reason for
him moving on from leaving the project
it makes a lot of sense and it does sound
exactly like what happened with the
Deadpool 2 movie you know director has
an idea for a vision of the film it
isn't necessarily in line with like the
universe that the studio's trying to
create so if you remember all the
craziness early this year with the
transition to the Geoff Johns era of DC
films. I think this Director Rick Famuyiw
was brought on before that transition
had been made and before they had
reevaluated what they wanted their film
universe to look like. So like a lot of
that transition happen while they were
making the Justice League movie so no
surprise that when they change their
focus in Hollywood it takes a long time
for that to actually bear fruit
so whereas they kind of started making
these films in a really dark gritty
universe and that was kind of like there
go to thing like okay we're going to
differentiate these from other studios
comic-book films by making them super
dark super serious and visually stunning
audiences are extremely divided on that
take so in comes Geoff Johns and they sort
of like recenter a lot of their
character work on sort of the true
spirit of the comic book characters so
like even if you have characters doing
things that they didn't do in the comics
the goal now is to keep the true spirit
of the characters alive in the movies so
it makes total sense that the director
of the Flash movie now had like this
darker grittier version of the flash
universe then they wanted to go with so
they decided to part ways like what
they're doing is trying to prevent
another suicide squad situation where
you have a director you know who has
like a really interesting idea for a
film but halfway through the process
they decide that the audience wants
something different so they try to
change the film after they've already
made a whole bunch of it so they're
basically trying to prevent a complete
nightmare down the road so it's probably
going to happen now is they'll find
another director it'll totally be fine
but it
will cause the release date of the movie
to get pushed originally it was supposed
to come out March 16 2018 meaning that
depending on how long it takes to find
another director it'll just get pushed X
number of months I don't think it would
get pushed any later than spring 2019 I
don't think it'll be that late they
might just choose to release it later in
the year in 2018 but if you remember
James Gunn said this really interesting
thing we said he felt like a lot of
really good ideas for big movies not
just comic book movies but big movies
in general got ruined because the
studios announced release dates before
the scripts were finished before
everything was figured out and I would
say that the biggest problem you have
today with movies is that people are
putting films in theaters of- that they
decide when a movie is going to come out
in the theater and then they start
work on that project
well the way it used to be is people
used to write a screenplay when the
screenplay was good enough the movie
would get greenlit and then they would
make that movie so the screenplay's were
better today they decide when a movie
is going to come out based on whatever
that IP is that product and then they
have to write to meet that date and the
script isn't good enough in the six
months you have to write that screenplay
then they still have to make the movie
no matter what because they've already
committed to a date and I think it's
really destroyed a lot of the quality of
filmmaking and that's why so many movies
are so bad
so now it sounds like both Marvel and DC
are just taking their time a little bit
more in getting these movies done which
i think is going to be much better in
the long run as much of a bummer is it
is that we won't get the Flash movie
quicker we'll get a much better movie
rather than try to rush out a half-baked
version of Flash movie you know better
to wait a couple more months and get
like a really awesome movie rather than get a
couple months quicker and get a really
terrible movie
so let's talk about tone because that's
actually a really big think that was the
big point of contention that caused the
director to leave it sounds like they're
trying to go with something that reads
maybe closer to say like geoff johns
running the comics imagine the tone of
those they weren't always like really
light and happy but they were certainly
a lot more hopeful and sunny than what
you've seen in the DC movies so far so
you can understand how like that vision
would clash with doing something really
super dark
and gritty but as far as we know that
doesn't necessarily mean they're going
to be changing a whole bunch of plot or
the big villains supposedly the Rogues
were going to be the villains of the
Flash movie so like Captain Cold was
going to be the big bad but they had
released some concept art of the the
Flash movie version of Captain Cold and
he just looked like a complete nightmare
like the scariest version of Captain
Cold you could possibly imagine
so far different from the TV show I'm
totally cool with the movie looking
completely different from the TV show I
think that's kind of the goal is to just
kind of do their own version while at
the same time being very true to the
spirit of the Barry Allen character but you
could just imagine the hilarity of a bunch of
little kids going to see the Flash movie
and just all the nightmare fuel of what
like this dark version of the flash
might have been the good thing about
this though is that by the time we get
to comic-con next year they will
actually have some flash movie stuff to
show us because they'll be getting ready
to roll out justice league so like
really Justice League will be the big
thing that DC's promoting at
comic-con next year that's a November
movie so you know comic-con end of july
they'll have like a whole bunch of
Justice League stuff but because it
takes about a year in post-production to
get a movie out they'll probably already
have a bunch of Flash movie stuff shot
but you know depending on when they
find their director when they get the
script and when they start shooting so
just be prepared for delays to happen
and really I think you know when they
talk about the shifting tone of the DC
movies in the Geoff Johns era Wonder
Woman is going to be the earliest
example of that like Geoff Johns was
heavily involved in the development in
the script for Wonder Woman so just
remember cycling directors out you know
stuff being changed at this point in
time is really just an example of a
transition from like the old DC movies
ethos to the new Geoff Johns era so I'm
also really interested to see how that
affects the Aquaman movie just because
there's so much like undersea horror
going on I think it's gonna be a lot of
fun
they said that Jason Momoa is going to be
something of a swashbuckler in the movie
it sounds like a lot of fun like you
can't go to a Jason Momoa movie without
having fun but in related DC news and I
just talked about Wonder Woman there is
a new Wonder Woman trailer like an
actual new trailer dropping with Dr.
Strange
this week in the united states so
that will probably post on like Thursday
maybe Wednesday night so whenever that
comes I'll totally do a video for it so
be sure to subscribe to get that. And there's a
whole bunch of DC and Marvel stuff
happening this week i'll probably post a
Super Girl Fight Club video tomorrow
morning they're basically doing like a
fight club episode on Supergirl where she just
beat the shit out a lot of people Miss
Martian is part of that too so it's
gonna be a lot of fun and Deacon Lachman
is coming on the show as Roulette so
that will probably post before The Flash
episode post tomorrow there's some
Infamous Iron Man, Dr. Doom stuff that I
want to do from the comics so get hype it's
gonna be awesome
don't worry you know flash movie you
know like it sounds like terrible that
the director would leave but it's really
not that bad
Geoff Johns I've come to bargain so
while you guys wait for that next video
to post you can click here for the flash
trailer for tomorrow's episode and you
can click here for my non-spoilery
Doctor Strange review thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight